it was reported
that a school district police officer
confronted
the suspect that was making entry
not accurate
he walked in unrestructed initially so
from
the grandmother's house to the bar ditch
to the school
into the school
he was not confronted by anybody
to clear the record on that
shocking developments in the tragedy in
texas that left 19 children and two
teachers dead authorities updating the
timeline on what happened and changing
key facts they now say the gunman was
not confronted by a school safety
officer and instead was able to walk
into what police think was an unlocked
door at the school without any
resistance here is everything we know at
this moment
at 11 28 am the gunman crashes his car
near the school
gets out and immediately starts shooting
at two people at a nearby funeral home
the suspect then jumps the school's
fence and starts firing at the building
at 11 40 a.m the gunman enters the
school quote unobstructed by going
through what authorities believe was an
unlocked door he then goes down a
hallway and into the classroom where
police say he starts shooting
four minutes later local police arrive
confront the gunman and this happens
you hear gunfire they take rounds
they move back
get cover
they don't make entry initially because
of the gunfire they're receiving
but we have officers calling for
additional resources
everybody that's in the area
tactical teams we need equipment we need
specialty equipment we need body armor
we need precision riflemen
negotiators
one hour later a border patrol tactical
team arrives breaches the classroom and
kills the suspect a bullet grazes the
hat of that brave agent who shot the
animal dead
all right jesse i'll go to you
what we found out today is what everyone
familiar with this predicted and that is
that it is always a fluid situation the
facts always change because no one has a
real grasp on them in situations like
this and now we went from an officer
confronted the
the shooter
to an officer encountered a shooter and
was injured by the shooter to now no
officer was on the scene so i guess
that's proof positive that you know we
can't rely on everything that's reported
we don't know what the facts are yet but
i think the thing that is the biggest
concern
is there is an hour wait
between when the police forgo first go
and get shot at back out and then try to
assess what's going on so they ripped up
the playbook after columbine in
columbine they waited until they had a
tactical team and then they went in big
but that was 40 minutes that they waited
in columbon so they don't do that
anymore the new protocol is is there's
an active shooter situation in a school
you immediately go directly towards the
gunfire and you engage the shooter and
you take the shooter out
the reason you do that is because you
have to assume that every round you hear
go off from the shooter is a bullet
going through a child right so it's it's
an immediate rush towards the shooter
and
that also distracts the shooter from
killing children because he now has to
engage law enforcement
and so they didn't do that here
i don't know why they didn't do that
we're going to figure that out but they
should have been trained to do that also
they should have if this door was locked
they should have a key like the fire
department has a key okay so let's be
clear
let's be clear on what you're talking
about it was unlocked where the
assailant goes in but then when the
police tried to go in it was locked
we've heard a few stories about the
locked door i don't know the truth about
that they also need breaching tools
you're going to show up and you can't
bust down a door if you're law
enforcement they should have that in
their units also they should have
tourniquets on site either at the school
or they should have tourniquets in the
police cruisers because if you go in
and and eliminate the suspect then you
have children bleeding to death in there
and if you wait 40 minutes an hour
without giving them medical aid you
could have saved lives and that that
every second is costly they did a study
on this the secret service 85 of school
shootings 85
happen in five minutes or less exactly
so this is so critical that you have
this
every second counts and i don't know
if they're not telling the truth about
what happened if it's the fog of war
while we're getting different
information but it's now really hard to
trust what you're hearing about what
happened that day all right you know
harold one of one of the issues is that
they have to assess whether it's a
hostage situation whether it is a
barricaded shooter situation or whether
it's an active shooter situation and
until they have people around who can
assess that they can keep going toward
the fire which is the easy answer but
they have to assess what it is that's
going on in the school so i mean there
is some
some leeway we have to give to the
police plus when you go onto a scene
like this who's in charge the local
police the school district police the
fbi the atf the deputy sheriffs who's in
charge i mean we've got to give them a
little space of course we have to and
again my prayers as i know they all of
ours do go out to these families into
this community but to to build on
jesse's point we as a pedestrians and as
parents of students or kids in those
schools we assume that teachers know
their job that police officers in law
enforcement know their job so i it can't
be for me to under to try to figure out
to sort out who's in charge on the scene
i would assume that that would be the
case i've read probably one of the more
interesting if not
daunting statements and reports i read
also is to some of the things you guys
were talking about was that they were
telling parents that they could not go
in
and that the police officers were not
going in either now
i would probably be dead today judge if
i were on the scene because they would
have had to shoot me or really really
take strong action i'm not that big of a
guy but if my georgia and heffe were in
that school
there's no no way whatsoever my mental
and emotional and physical makeup would
have allowed me not to go now if you're
a police officer i think a question has
to be asked not of generally police
officers but there
why wouldn't you have done exactly what
you said it's been
3448 days since the killing the killing
of the kids at sandy hook we've had 900
shootings in schools across the country
since then that's one shooting every
four days more than that uh over a
period of time there has to be protocols
for this but look
i agree with you let's let more of the
facts come forward but as facts do come
forward it is it can only
be even more painful for the families
and for the parents in that community
you know what greg i want you to listen
to this sound and i agree with harold
i'd be dead today too this is the sound
of the parents
[Music]
[Applause]
while the police are assessing what to
do those parents are screaming the
children are bleeding out if indeed they
were shot for the first few minutes
yeah i mean it's terrible and no doubt
there will be investigations uh there
are devastated parents this is
how truth unfolds it unfolds over time
and it's always been my personal feeling
that you let the truth unfold over time
you know uh i know that we're
criticizing the reaction times of the
police
but it's not like we're experts
and we do this a lot but i would rather
just wait for the facts to come out uh i
mean sure you could argue should they
have gone right in or should they have
waited for swat what what was their
training but i'm not going to pretend
that we're right when we come to
situations i mean we're the media we're
terrible at rushing to judgment we we
push out a lot of inaccurate
material a lot of the facts that have
come out in this story have turned out
not to be true so we're getting another
bite in the apple of the story and i
just
would rather just pull back and start
condemning people and what they should
have done and what they should not have
done because the facts always end up
changing in this stuff it always does so
i don't think there's any benefit to
pushing out information whether it is
inaccurate or not because frankly what
the hell do we know really what the hell
do we know we don't know we weren't
there but you know katie president biden
just the other day said that with his
executive order he was going to limit
the transfer of military hardware to
police departments had these police
officers had body bunkers ballistic
shields different uh different tech
different uh
you know technology whatever you want to
call it they could have gone in without
waiting an hour they could have
confronted him i'm so glad you brought
that out because i was going to bring it
up as well you know they're dhs in the
past has been capable of transferring
military type equipment to local police
departments like uvalde texas which is a
very small town that doesn't have
enormous resources they don't have a big
tax base so they need
funding or equipment from the federal
government to be on the same level in
terms of their training should something
like this horrific you know something
this horrific happen
in their community it's difficult it's
expensive the training takes a lot of
time so that is one aspect of this the
other is that
as we now see in the reporting and the
press conference today there was not a
an armed officer on scene
there was the door was unlocked for the
guy to walk right into the school there
was no security at all none there was
nothing to stop this person there's
nothing to slow him down there's no
deterrence and it was too late i mean
the the old saying is when seconds count
the police are minutes behind and that's
exactly what happened here it's
interesting to look at the timeline with
border patrol and vortex showing up
before these about 50 miles from the
border
i'm curious to know the the the events
there and why a swat team couldn't get
there more quickly the video of the the
police standing outside with their long
guns what kind of firearms did the
initial police officers go into the
school with did they just go in with
handguns or did they go in with rifles
lots of questions about
how they handled that but the idea that
there wasn't a single
thing to stop this person
changes everything i mean just imagine
if the door was locked and you know we
learned from parkland that you have to
keep the doors closed from the nicholas
cruz cage uh a case and now
you know we find out the door was not
closed also the district employs four
school resource officers that uvalde
school district there are eight schools
so four
school resource officers can't possibly
be at eight schools hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else